so
in blackbox there's kind of a lot of
really cutting-edge psychological and
technological and scientific
theories and ideas going on and i'm
curious what your reaction was
when you first read that in the script
and if there's any kind of research you
did
to sort of get acquainted to that world
oh absolutely there was research i did
to support being dr
lilly and brooks absolutely there was
research
in uh neurophysics um
the theories the treatments
the
[Music]
therapies the terms
and uh and and speak
her dialogue with the measure of um
knowledge and authority it was very
important to be able to do
that makes a lot of sense and how do you
kind of
perform this these sort of terms and
jargon
while also keeping it emotionally
engaging and interesting
it's the language she speaks it's to the
language
yeah yeah it's the language she speaks
by virtue of her
a profession and her
um her acumen
is it sort of like i know you do a lot
of theater is it kind of like
reacquainting or acquainting yourself
with
the way that like an august wilson
writes dialogue or the way that like a
shakespeare writes dialogue is it sort
of just
getting into this mode of speaking or is
there something different or deeper
about it
hmm that's a very good question
always you want to know what your
character's
words mean to them you know
sometimes the language is simpler
sometimes it's more poetic
sometimes it's complicated and
convoluted
this was pretty straightforward
from her as a professional person
speaking to
um speaking to a patient
you know or to a group of peers
it's just her language it's the language
she speaks yeah
what is it like to play such a strong
secret what's kind of the what is it
like to walk the line of
how much of that to show early on versus
how much of it to keep to the chest
well you think about what a secret would
mean to you
if it's a secret do you display any of
it
if you do it's not a secret
if it's a secret it's a secret and you
keep it
yeah yeah so this this character was
very good at not letting any of this
show would you say
she didn't want any of it to show and
once
she kind of reveals that to her son did
it feel cathartic as either performer or
being this character to
let that kind of be unleashed what did
it feel like to finally say it out loud
there was some release in that some
relief in that too
because um
because there was i'm trying not to give
everything away sir
i see i appreciate that uh we can keep
it a little more general
um what was kind of the
what was sort of the backstory you
created for this character there's a
moment when you mention
her husband uh thomas's father and
having kind of a
difficult family life what was some of
the work done for that
well yeah that's that's what actors do
you know
you create that for yourself and it's
not something that you necessarily
share with anyone else uh
but you create it for yourself so you
understand you have a life
the character has a life uh that is
unseen that supports what is seen
that's wonderful um did you work on that
with
the director at all the first time
director or was that mostly
just an interior journey well
this was that's a very interesting
question too we we
we talked a little bit about it and um
and and i smile because
at one point i looked at him and i said
you've never been married have you
and he blushed
you learn
[Laughter]
and he was so good natured to allow me
to do that
you know but i listened to what he had
to say
because it was important um
it was important because in listening to
what he had to say
i understood what it was he was reaching
for
how would you characterize what he was
reaching for
he wanted he wanted lillian
to have an emotional depth
that was concealed
and it was part of her nature to conceal
it
uh it had to do with a number of things
her position and standing in her
professional community
the way she would appear to people as a
consummate
scientist research scientist
neurophysicist
you have to comport yourself in a
certain way
you know and she did that she did that
very well
and anything uh in the way of a personal
challenge
or sense of failure
in any area of life was never discussed
with anyone
that was something that was held yeah
she's a very private person
um shifting gears just a little bit
i'm very fond of your performance in the
creed movies both of them and i know
that
creed 3 is slowly getting in the works
i'm curious if you've seen
any part of that process or if there's
anything you're excited about that
i like the i like the films i enjoy
watching them
yeah so i whether i'm in it or not
i'll enjoy watching it oh i understood
gotcha
um and i have to
imagine it's a bit of an actor's bucket
list to be asked to
perform a voice role in a pixar film
which you're doing
in the upcoming soul what is uh what was
it like
performing in a pixar film what is that
process like
i had a ball i had a great time yeah
it's so wonderful to work with people
who are
listening and whose notes and
adjustments are
so fine and particular
because you get to fine-tune yourself
yeah and your performance and i liked
that i liked that
very much what were uh some of the
differences you found
in voice acting versus traditional
full-body acting
well when it's just your voice you focus
that way
and you i i have to say
i listened in new ways
because you're always listening as an
actor you have to listen
you know always listening yeah but
listening in new ways and i had the same
experience
with jingle jangle when
there you will see when you see the film
there is
there are parts of it that involve
narration
and the character that i portray is
doing that
and the director david talbert
very very keen and specific
and detailed in what he was hearing
and i think it had much to do with the
fact that when he was a little boy
his grandmother would read to him
a lot and he treasures those memories
and
and i could tell by the notes that he
was giving me
um that that had a real impression on
him a lasting impression
and i enjoyed that tremendously so i've
had this
vocal work and another thing that i have
done within the past
year and a half
were kobe bryant's books his wisdom arts
these books
yeah i did four and
that was amazing reading those
for audio for audio books
they make good reading for young people
and adults as well i enjoyed reading
them
i thought oh no where's the next one
so i've had a really good stretch of
vocal work
in recording in this past year and a
half
and uh and it really
it really does heighten appreciation for
spoken word
yeah and that kind of takes us back to
dr lillian's use of language
and one sort of final i know we'll try
to be a little general about this black
box question
um but the ending moments with your
character
she makes a let's call it a discovery
a new discovery and i'm curious what
you think are the next steps for the
doctor what what is
what happens after this moment i have no
idea
yeah i think that's up to the producer
and the writer i have no idea
is there like a black box 2 sequel in
the works
i have no idea
really i have no idea uh let's try and
end on something we
you do have some idea on what is your
relationship
with horror and sci-fi in general
uh is it something you enjoy or was it
kind of something
you had to get used to performing in
that mode
it's all acting you don't shift
the way you approach a character the way
you react to other
characters because the film
is uh straight drama
or because it's in the genre of what
some consider a psychological thriller
like tyler perry's a fall from grace
[Music]
or this which some people consider a
genre
they some people call it horror
so but it's and mama do is the one who
really expresses this most
clearly he says it's all acting
it's all serious play yeah and you can
tell
thank you so much for your time really
great talking to you thank you
take care all right